tu vois cette empreinte sais pas où ça
c'est la bête
voilà suivre bras mouton une semaine ça
suffit moi je sais pourquoi tu a mordu
la bête
puis calment quel tapis point ça si la
bête s'approche des moutons s'arrête aux
non voyants
[Musique]
pourquoi tu gâches le schéma que j'en ai
connu j'ai même connu des gars
conditionné sauver sa fille toujours
très mal
je le savais c'est pas toi qui les culés
moutons
[Musique]
ce côté bout ah bah non tu es belle
il reconnaît le verger qui tapait la
dette c'est pourquoi il a tapé
c'est pourquoi les gens font la guerre
toit est bonne pourquoi en fait tout
fait pour moi nous chasser des bêtes
nuisibles et on a beaucoup dans mon
talent beaucoup de trop ou comptait
régler sa commande chez les mères ont
organisé une battue et on leur à cette
date
pourquoi tu t'arrêtes va-t'en va-t'en
pousse toi tu bois tu es mon ami
tu es si belle quand voyant je t'aimais
[Musique]
mécontent
je te mets
[Musique]